when he goes off on Florida and the
coveted response and implies that
somehow New York did a better job do you
want to hit him harder I think he hurts
himself nobody in the Republican base
thinks co uh New York handled covet
better than Florida nobody believes that
it's not believable and in fact he
doesn't believe it because he said for
years how good Florida did he said I was
one of the great governors in America do
you want Trump to show up to the next
debate I think he owes it to the to the
public to debate I think the the idea
that he's entitled to be nominated is
absurd I think that there's a lot of
questions that he needs to answer both
about how he would win the election but
also about some of the decisions that he
made as president you pointed out the
fauci and then there are others